thank you for being with us America
we're glad you're here open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money we're talking about
index funds going into the break versus
mutual funds just give you a little bit
more on that because there's a lot of
barking out there that you know you
don't need an investment advisor you can
just pick a mutual fund and most mutual
funds don't outperform the S&P 500 which
actually is a true statement most don't
but that doesn't mean all don't most
people don't win the Super Bowl but
someone does and so which team do you
want to pick you know so here's the
thing over the last 40 years large cap
funds that are in existence today that
we own that are around 40 years old
there's 84 of them 34 in the growth
category that have outperformed the S&P
500 and actually I'm sorry out of the 84
30 of them helped performed the S&P 500
in the last 30 years there's a hundred
and seventy nine total 51 of them how
performed the S&P 500 in the last 20
years is four hundred and forty six
funds available in that population
growth we did the research on this
how many outperformed out of 446 the S&P
500 199 and in the last 10 years is nine
hundred and fifty seven basically a
thousand of them and somewhere around
1/4 of them 247 outperformed the S&P 500
in my current mix in my personal 401k my
return over the last 40 years
had I been in it exactly like that I've
not been in it the whole time like that
but if I bought those exact funds over
the last 40 years they would have
returned 13.04 percent as a group and
I've got one growth one growth in a
come one aggressive growth and one
international so I got made 13.04 during
a 40-year average the S&P during that
same period of time averaged eleven
point eight one
so while a hundred and while one point
two three percent one and a quarter
percent over forty years might not seem
like a lot if an investor puts ten
thousand dollars in forty years ago and
never puts anything else in this amount
grows to four hundred and eighty
thousand dollars extra
during that forty years because of one
and a quarter percent so returns do
matter and so had you done oh I'm just
gonna invest in S&P because I read an
article I would have made a half a
million dollars more for every ten
thousand dollars that I had invested
forty years ago then you made
that's what outperforming the market
means to you over the last thirty years
my mixes averaged eleven point three
percent the S&P has averaged ten point
eight nine over the last twenty years my
mixes averaged eight point five three
and the S P has averaged seven point one
two of course this includes the drop in
2008 in those numbers so once we get
past those numbers it's going to change
dramatically because there's an unusual
dip in the marketplace and the
historical data of the marketplace there
I own one particular mutual fund that
since its inception in 1973 and I've
owned it most that long has averaged 13
point four three percent during the 44
years I've been invested in that had I
been in it since it began I'm not quite
but had I been in it since it began out
of 44 years it has seven years it lost
money the oldest fund out there is ICA
Investment Company of America I actually
own some of it its annual return since
it started in 1934
is twelve point zero seven percent now
Ramsey says you can get dwell per se
Rebs he's lost his mind
I trust Dave Ramsey for getting out of
debt but you don't know anything about
investing because you can't get 12% and
you just bought that one fund you would
have and out of the 83 years that it's
been open fifteen of them are down years
and the rest are up that's a pretty
stable fund like very stable like safer
than your house fund so there's two
funds that I own right there one at 13.4
3 since 1973
and one averaging 12 points Evan since
1934 so I know you don't think you can
get 12% and I know some of you that are
CFPs
know where you can get this and others
of you that are CFPs are just certified
financial pharisees because you have
decided that it is absurd to expect
these kinds of rates of return that the
historical market data shows you is
actually there so what if you put money
in the mutual fund and I'm wrong well
I'm going with you for one thing because
I've got millions and millions and
millions of dollars in these funds so
I'm gonna lose a lot more than you so
shut up but let's just say that I'm
wrong that the fund that averaged 12
percent since 1934 or 13 point 4 3
percent since 1973 that they don't do
that well let's say they do half as good
now based on their history that would be
a bizarre freaking assumption
mathematically you'd have to be smoking
crack to get these things to do that but
let's just say they did half because
we're so far off in dreamland where is
it you're gonna get 7 percent on your
money again
half six percent on your money have you
been to the bank have you looked at CDs
there one one in the quarter where is
that you're gonna get seven so if I'm
half wrong you're still gonna get
wealthy the point is is for you to start
investing and quit getting paralysis of
the analysis and stop the stupidity of
worrying and fretting about being ripped
off on fees fees fees fees fees fees
fees fees fees fees fees fees you know
the ASP PA the actuary consultants
administrators and other retirement plan
professionals it's actually an
organization did a detailed research of
retirement success that models the
findings that we found as we studied
millionaires you know what the primary
driver of becoming wealthy at retirement
is according to this study the primary
driver seventy four percent of the
reason that people have wealth at
retirement is what's called savings rate
you need to find that for you
it means you saved money you put money
into the account the primary contributor
the primary reason that you become
wealthy is you actually freaking save
money it's not your rate of return which
I just went over some great rates of
return and it's not that you saved on
expenses and it's not that you're
golfing buddy gave you a stock tip or
your fishing buddy gave you a stock tip
the primary drivers seventy four percent
of the reason if you want to be
successful seventy four percent of the
time you'll be successful
that's a very high rate it is based on
you actually saving money the rate at
which you save money is the primary
driver it's not the rate of return it's
not a financial
advisor or not a financial adviser it's
not you read an internet article it's
not your broke brother-in-law's opinion
you actually saved money the rate at
which you save money causes you to
become wealthy though it's kind of
common sense isn't it you can't get to a
percent Dave I know I just told you a
fun where there's done that since 1934
and another one that did better than
that since 1973 but I know you can't in
the S&P during that same period times
eleven point eight so come on folk you
know what you want to do but it's time
to get your rate of saving your rate of
investing up because that's the primary
driver by which you become wealthy this
is the Dave Ramsey show